Said this, uh,
before, but I think that silent
saying women is the worst mistake that Donald Trump ever made.
This person to have outplay Donald Trump is.
Is. Is a porn star.
He's a, uh,
cheating pig. Um,
that's the best case scenario right now.
The worst case scenario is that,
you know, we don't know what these women know
that Donald Trump doesn't want us to know.
It's what Donald Trump did in reaction to that
that he's now going to possibly be paying for.
If I may quote Drake,
because I'm on your show, alright?
Am I. Do I have permission?
Please. Okay.
Bury me now. And I only get bigger
every time that he tries to bury you.
Get it right. Every time you try to bury one of these stories,
whether it's Stormy Daniels,
whether it's Karen Mcdougall or some reservoirs,
he's only made these women more powerful.